- [Narrator] Nature has always been
an integral part of my life.
It’s the place where I feel the most at peace.
People who have visual impairment
really have very limited
access to the outdoors.
To fix this problem, I
created a Braille trail.
(upbeat music)
- [Woman] Meet Evan, a
19-year-old who founded
Nature for All, an
organization that helps provide
nature experiences for
the visually impaired.
There are numerous challenges that
visually impaired people
face when they try
to enjoy nature, like uneven footing
and not being able to read the signs.
- [Man] Feel the rope.
Now you should be able to guide yourself.
- [Evan] A Braille trail has a guide rope
and signage in Braille
so the vision impaired
can walk along it unassisted.
It highlights sensory experiences
such as touching leaves
and textured bark.
Now everybody can enjoy nature.
- [Woman] He first came up with the idea
to make his own Braille trail
after he saw one that was vandalized.
- I was 11 years old when I started
getting involved with Braille trails.
I couldn't believe that
anybody would vandalize
a trail and take away the opportunity
that the visually impaired so seldom have
to go out and experience nature.
(people chatter)
- My name is Marsha Farrow and
I have retinitis pigmentosa.
- [Woman] Marsha has
been visually impaired
since elementary school.
- [Marsha] I have always loved nature.
I feel that I can be
independent when I'm out
at a Braille trail and
that this is an area
that I can enjoy and relax a little bit
without having to be so anxious
about what's coming ahead.
- [Woman] Since Evan
started his organization,
Braille trails have been popping up
all over the world and his website keeps
tabs on their location.
- Currently the website has over
200 Braille nature trails
and sensory gardens
in 35 countries on six continents.
Accessible outdoor
opportunities can bridge
the barrier between
people with disabilities
and the world outside.
- [Woman] And that goes for Evan, too.
- [Evan] I've become a lot closer
with the visually impaired community.
They have such a positive outlook on life
despite what they go through
and really they can do
just about anything that we can do.
They are really my role models.
(upbeat music)